it's too bad that you can't actually see
DNA easily under a microscope and scan
across the double helix and read out the
sequence of bases that amounts to the
information content because it would be
easier I think to explain then how a
geneticist goes about tracking down the
molecular basis of a disease at the DNA
level our methods are indirect they're
very powerful they're very highly
accurate but they're not as visual as
you might like we do have methods though
now that allow you to read out with high
accuracy all three billion of the
letters of the DNA instruction book
those letters are actually these
chemical bases the chemical language of
DNA is a simple one there's only four
letters in the alphabet those bases that
we abbreviate AC G and T and we have
methods of being able to compare then
the DNA sequence of people who have a
disease versus people who don't and look
for the critical differences in order to
nail down something that might be the
cause well since however we all differ
in our DNA sequence by about 1/2 of 1%
you wouldn't get very far if you
basically sequenced my DNA and the DNA
of somebody with Parkinson's disease
trying to figure out what the
differences were because it would be way
too many of them but if you're willing
to do that for a large number of people
you kind of average out all the noise
and the difference that matters begins
to be more and more clear that's an
overly simplified description of how a
geneticist goes about zeroing in on the
actual molecular cause of a complex or a
simple disease this worked most readily
for diseases that are highly heritable
cystic fibrosis Huntington's disease
those are conditions where a single
mutation very reproducibly results in
the disease it's been a lot tougher for
diseases where the inheritance is muddy
if you take diabetes for instance which
is what my lab primarily works on or you
take asthma or high blood pressure that
is not
set of conditions where one gene is
involved in risk there are dozens of
genes involved in that and no single one
of them contributes very much but you
put it all together and the consequence
to that individual may tip them over the
threshold into having the illness we're
in the throes right now trying to sort
that part out for the common diseases
that we know have hereditary influences
because they run in families but they're
much more complicated than say cystic
fibrosis
there were a lot of supply surprises a
lot of times where you just marveled at
what you had uncovered and felt like you
must have really somehow missed it when
you were making guesses about what would
be there I guess the one that startled
most of us the most profoundly was how
few protein coding genes there actually
are in the genome the old paradigm about
DNA makes RNA makes protein well then a
stretch of DNA is gonna make a protein
how many genes does it take to specify a
human being who you would think it would
be an exorbitant number and various
estimates had been put forward before we
knew the answer and that we're in the
neighborhood of a hundred 150,000
ultimately it turns out we only have
about 20,000 protein coding genes a
breath-taking a short list of
instructions for an organism as complex
as homo sapiens
there are other genes that don't code
for protein that are turning out to be
pretty important so in a certain way
we're rescuing our sense of complexity
by discovering their other categories of
genes that don't have to be the protein
coding sort but it is still astounding
to think that just 20,000 of these
protein coding genes is enough to take a
single cell which we all once were and
inspire this program of elaborate
complex development into a human being
including a nervous system which is
beyond our ability to present time to
even quite contemplate because of its
complexity